coronavirus in China is now blamed for
more than 900 deaths including one
American the death toll is larger than
the SARS epidemic in 2002 and 2003 the
outbreak aboard a cruise ship in Japan
is getting worse with more than 130
confirmed cases including some two dozen
Americans Debora patta spoke to one of
them I saluted and confined to a
hospital bed nothing could be further
removed from Rebecca Frazier's idea of a
dream holiday in Asia shattered after
learning she was one of the more than
two dozen Americans who tested positive
for corona virus it was a very surreal
experience to be told that you have this
virus that you know as far as I knew
could be deadly at that point although I
didn't feel at all Frazier said it was
pretty scary being separated from her
husband Kent and taken from the ship to
hospital where she won't be allowed to
leave for at least two weeks so what's
the first thing you're gonna do when you
get out of there
when they get out of here just get back
to my husband as soon as I can
more than 3600 people remain quarantined
on the ship in a show of solidarity
President Xi Jinping toured the streets
of Beijing wearing a protective face
mask his administration has been accused
of failing to respond to early warnings
about the corona virus dr. Lee wen Liang
who died last week was silenced when he
sounded the alarm late last year
Chinese ambassador swea responded on
Face the Nation yesterday I don't know
who tried to assign us him but there was
certainly
disagreement what exactly the virus is
in Hong Kong authorities have imposed a
14 day quarantine for anyone from
mainland China already over 1,000 people
have been given quarantine orders and
police have issued warrants of arrest
for two people who escaped from the
Amanda
isolation turning Debora patta forests
in Hong Kong Deborah thank you very much